ils sont arrivés d'un village de
l'oeuvre qui comme le patron des
amoureux porte le nom de saint valentin
ils ont avec ces charmants petits
animaux découvert paris et sa tour
eiffel c'est aujourd'hui leur fait et
c'est en pensant à eux que nous avons
invité ce soir dans nos studios deux
artistes d'un genre différent
l'un a dessiné ses éternelle fiancée et
l'autre les chante
écoutez et regardez au quatrième étage
c'est là que fini l'escalier au dessus
via le toit mais au dessus du toit
il y a il y a qu'est ce qu'il ya au
dessus les toits raymond séné
il y a un jeu un travail de
collaboration c'est pas beau perchée sur
ce nuage se tient tout un monde caché
paradis merveilleuse éternellement bleue
pour les enfants sages je fis noires et
chapeau ou pas je le fais loi on s'en va
prendre trop de temps un ça va prendre
trop de temps
la petite famille les amoureux de ce
fait les rives sur ce nuage
ils ont cet air désuet des amants de
notre âge
les amoureux de peynet c'est lui dans
l'eure marivaudage échange des serments
et des choeurs j'avais pris trop sur
papier d'emballage
je vois là une chanson plutôt hachée
n'est ce pas exactement les abonnés au
fond c'est leur fête aujourd'hui ce prêt
oui la saint valentin
oui bien sûr moi je dis toujours la
savoie la fin ça devrait être fait
nationale ou la sabena
pourquoi saint pée n'est tout simplement
sa maman et gut devançait l'amont les
amants et de tenait au fond ça marquer
un changement dans votre carrière à une
révolution une révolution
jusque là j'étais un comédien et un
fantaisiste
ti de chanter que des choses que je ne
pouvais pas me passer du rire du public
pendant plus de trente secondes je
croyais que ça ne marchait pas et un
jour aznavour m'a amené une chanson qui
s'appelait les amoureux de peynet
d'ailleurs je dois dire je n'ai osé la
chanter que parce que la chute était
drôle mais pendant deux minutes tout de
même ça n'était que de la poésie de la
tendresse et vous connaissiez peiné
n'ont pas été reçus ça qu'est la côte de
l'est et j'avais beaucoup d'admiration
pour lui je connais ses dessins avant
même de faire ce métier et on a été mis
en contact chez paypal allait se passer
quelque chose
je me souviens vous avoir vu pour la
première fois c'était à vomir à bobino
oui et vous chantez avec un petit melon
et marc valade
voilà alors ça ne va plus quand même
écrit tout de suite aimé peigne été
amenés à nous des cyniques que des
amoureux je ne sais pas où sont ces
c'est ainsi un volontaire je crois que
ça remonte à une vingtaine d'années je
me promenais dans balance et j'ai
découvert à valence sur un kiosque à
musique qui est très amusant et j'ai
tout de suite par des formations
professionnelles j'ai bien défunt est à
l'origine ce petit personnage cheveux
longs et est un musicien dit violoniste
et peut-être sent inutile tout seul sur
la feuille de papier
les bus une petite panne est arrivé et
c'est de là que sont nées les amoureux
alors sans frantz fanon
mais valentin france dresse le kiosque à
musique a été baptisé l'année dernière
le kiosque des amoureux 1 c'est drôle et
c'est lui qui a déterminé cette offre
qui ont dès le départ ça a été le départ
les hameaux de peiner en 20 ans oui bah
merci oui mais moi aussi j'ai toujours
20 ans qu'est ce que c'est c'est un peu
quand tu auras 20 ans et un s'étonnant
chênois lâcheté l'enchaînement est oui
eh bien oui bien effet je continue donc
depuis cette époque où j'ai osé chanter
mes chansons tendres il ya deux choses
dans mon tour de chant des chansons
gaies et des chansons qui font qu'on
m'appelle et j'en suis bien et je suis
bien heureux et ma chère madame
il faut qu'on m'appelle le petit
amoureux de peynet alors j'ai toujours
des petites chansons bien ton nom bien
gentil comme quand tu rends maintenant
que je vais vous chanter tout de suite
bridge a tout fait à les y voilà alors
raymond je vous laisse le papier vous
finissez par vous prendrez vous
germaine alors je vais chanter ma petite
chanson alors ça va bien mal dormi 1
quand aura 20 ans tous les hommes seront
freine donc prochain soit on égale doha
des gants blancs et un grand roger
lycopène
car tu seras caporal général à cheval
sur ton soleil avec ses grands effets
dora des galons et infos chapeau pointu
sur les tétées du mot fichu que c'est de
faire peur aux chabot c'est qu'au lieu
de faire la risette qui m'a fichu des
babines qui font fuir jumbo et bambi les
petites marionnettes celles qui feront
comprendre dans quel est ton péché dans
sa pré 3 pirouette quand aura 20 ans il
y aura une jolie da dont tu seras prince
charmant la torah 32 dents et quand tu
diras ce sésame ses bras s'ouvriront
tous grands qui ont six mois pour un
sens qui sera dans le secret des
demoiselles comme un polichinelle
deftera je joue en voilà en veux tu tu
me répéter
la vie enfin sens ce sera concret la
crise que ses partenaires quand j'aurai
vingt ans les sommes seront intelligents
on attrape sera là lui dans 20 ans 3 20
ans dort à 20 en voiture et moi j'aurai
vingt ans de plus
et moi j'aurai vingt ans depuis qu'ils
ont quitté